obviously one of the key components of
the black widow character is this
enigmatic pass which is still affecting
and defining her but it seems at the end
of this movie Utley she's perhaps a lot
more receptive to maybe people known a
bit more that entails so would you as an
actress be interested in going there and
exploring that and realizing little film
or do you think perhaps some things
about left undefined and it crushed
Rob the character of some of her
intrigue in history um
well you'll get more of widows backstory
in in Avengers 2 also really yeah um and
and I think her backstories I mean she
has a rich rich past as you just you
know already described she's um she
definitely comes from a really dark past
um you know I think she's kind of had to
be sort of she's had to sort of D
sensitize or dehumanize in a way to be
able to do and see some of the things
that she's you know I'm seen and
participated in willingly and they're
probably most people that have that kind
of job
um description you know a mercenary they
do um but I think she's just sort of now
grappling with the fact that she may be
experiencing some trauma from that or at
least that she has feelings about the
things that that she's might maybe she
doesn't sleep so well at night and and
you know it's just sort of hitting her
now that she's kind of been you know
acting as a sort of um you know
gun-for-hire
and you know that in doing that she's
never really made any active choices and
that kind of it's sort of like the rug
has been she's kind of pulled from under
her feet so I think more interestingly
what would hallowed be to discover her
you know to follow the progression of
that story and you know bring her back
home or see where that see where that
kind of leads to but of course you know
that's all in my imaginary next
installment you know none of that's
really been you know we've thrown a ball
around a little bit but um nothing is in
the works right now for that Scarlett
Johansson Captain America has his shield
and Falcon come fly you only have two
small girls have you ever asked for
anything more to protect yourself as
effects in the film and the second
question is do how do you identify with
black below well I have a bite I have a
widow's bite and uh you know all kinds
of things that come out of my IVA belt
it's multi-purpose um and I have my wit
of course my sensational wit um my kung
fu like wit uh and um i i i don't know i
mean i i'm i think part of the widow's
fighting style and what makes her sort
of charming is that she uses her size
against you know her opponent and kind
of its to her advantage that she's
fighting these big dudes and she's this
kind of quick and quick thinking you
know click on her feet kind of house is
hard now it's hard to catch can't teach
quick love that yeah kena yeah and and
and i mean i think that the the i I have
like I think that I I don't know
necessarily how do I identify with her
wall I mean I think any character that
you play you have to be um sympathetic
towards of course because you know even
if it's if that's a villainous character
um that's what makes you could sort of I
always have to have that bit of
likability to you um I think this
character has a certain unexpected
humility to her that's kind of SH is
that soft underbelly and and I have that
theme song not that you do that you did
you